c'est reparti pour les casse tête et
c'est reparti pour le casse tête
salut tout le monde j'ai découvert
récemment un truc qui m'a fait sur qui
fait il ya une collection de castets
sherlock holmes
donc je suis tombé sur cette boîte
sherlock holmes avec avec le petit
scénario derrière et tout c'est une
boîte casse tête comme on aime
depuis je me dis [ __ ] c'est fou il ya
pas de la collection il ya trois trucs
donc bah enfin je les ai achetés tous
les trois du coup parce que vraiment je
n'arrive pas à me retenir
il y à un autre casse-tête qui est comme
ça on voit le 221b baker street
et là il y en a avec une bonne vieille
pipe vous avez toujours plaisir de ce
petit clip tu vas pour deux casses tête
d'un objet ça change des voitures
comprendre l'oif pour les amateurs de
pipe exactement donc ce que je propose
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de résoudre
les trois si c'est trop long si je
galère sur un et bien on s'arrêtera au
bout de deux peut-être et puis je ferai
le troisième dans une autre vidéo mais
on va essayer de d'étape et tous les
trois lui par exemple j'ai peur de le
taper vite et eux aussi ont peur que je
veux tu habites parce qu'ils ont rajouté
en plus des petits trucs denning
d'allumettes dans une boîte d'allumettes
à ça on va pas le faire relou aucun
intérêt on connaît ça on connaît bien
déjà les bye au tamis mon instagram à
moi tu es gentil le hic un oubli jamais
levé la main sur sa me fait rire il ya
plein de gens des fois j'ai postulé les
commentaires qu'ils ou loïc avec ses
blagues il se permet trop
il ya des messages comme ça je me dis
mais vraiment vous croyez qu'on ne
travaille pas ensemble qu'on monte pas
les trucs ensemble qu'on réfléchisse pas
ensemble et quand il ya plein d'idées à
lui évidemment que je les valides en
fait la vidéo et tu la diffuser et moi
je regardais je suis après jeu mais
[ __ ] rick ça c'est vrai c'est drôle
bon ça reste anecdotique gars c'est pas
souvent mais en vrai c'est stylé 1 c'est
super joli ans je sais pas si je le
ferais gagner cela je dis peut-être mais
les garder non je rigole le ferait
gagner sur mon instinct
comme d'hab si vous voulez chercher ils
sont pour le coup de stress pas
l'édition limitée ils sont très
facilement trouvable sur internet je
vous mettrai le lien dans la description
comme d'hab je veux pas trop abîmer
parce que puisque je le ferais gagner
sur sur mon instagram tout le poste que
vous voyez apparaître maintenant je veux
pouvoir tour packagée comme c'était à
l'origine
[Musique]
comme tu veux pas la caractéristique
première de sherlock holmes du sud alors
l'appui pas ce qu'est ce que ça nous
qu'est ce que ça nous indique sa ket
louis blues est tobacco from the by
without moving en gros est ce qu'on peut
enlever ça sans toucher quoi sans
toucher la petite lou sans toucher le
tabac donc on n'a pas le droit de faire
ça pas hausser un tabac suppose it donc
en clair faut sortir sa de la peep
semble touché ok nous allons entrer dans
une première phase d'observation
l'un dernière d'être une pipe en bois et
mes analyses sont formelles loïc ce
tabac avait pas du vrai tabac on ne peut
pas être ceci n'est pas une bonne heure
puis alors loïc j'ai commencé mon orgue
est comme sherlock holmes c'était un
livre on sait pas vraiment là vous tirez
et d'après moi il paraît un petit peu
comme ça le week-end au terme cher en
scène et du coup moriarty lequel voit
qu'ils parleraient pas au québec ou à
montréal tu es station je te faire péter
big ben tu vas pas comprendre
on va lui mettre à nu taxant il sera
belle j'aime plutôt me retire bon ok
j'ai ouais mais j'ai déjà un début
d'idée c'est à dire que si j'ai pas le
droit de toucher la pipe est obligé de
la laisser comme ça on va le faire très
logiquement les amis ont donc il faut
que je fasse une action indirecte sens
physique qui permettent de bouger sa
première idée je renverse la table et si
tout tombe ça ça sort et je rempli la
condition
le tabac est sorti j'ai pas touché à
pipe j'ai pas touché le tabac quelque
chose me dit que ce n'est pas la
solution attendue du coût deuxième
solution
moi j'ai une idée on verra si tu as
l'idée dit moi aussi là si vous avez une
idée dans les commentaires du boulot moi
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on peut utiliser
qui impacte de la force sur un objet
qu'on n'a pas le droit de toucher
moi je vois qu'une celui de solutions
dans la une en tête ou pathologique
c'est à dire ouais c'est vrai hockey
dites moi dans les commentaires à les y
aident à déterminer
il fallait être beaucoup plus réactif
que ça des amis c'est quoi ton le
l'outil ou l'accessoire que tu les
utiliserait pas me dire tu vas
démonstration go voir un dentiste avec
tes vieilles dents de chameau ne marche
pas ne marche pas il a cherché sa voie
elle seule sait le souffle le vent le
souffle
ça permet de de faire quelque chose sans
y toucher et la chose que vous voyez
peut-être si l'ol veut bien vous faire
un zoom dessus c'est qu'on voit un bel
interstices entre le tabac et le et la
peep
c'est à dire que sa forme lac est comme
ça arrondit pour moi c'est pas hasard
donc je vais tenter de souffler et
soufflé jusqu'à ce que ta maison
s'envole
j'arrive pas souffler ça me chatouille
l'effet propre et un bien sûr mais
surtout vous connaissez mon père
maintenant c'est son point faible
il souffle oui oui bof
alors on va pas se mentir avec les durs
faut être deux bon en tout cas celui ci
est résolu ok ils étaient fastoche je
dois tout fait dans les autres parce que
alors là c'est vraiment si je devais un
jour sauver le monde et qu'il faut
souffler sur une bougie jeu fait râler
je savais à quel moment tu fais
référence
ah oui oui à bord a barboté je suis fait
arrêter de chatouiller comme ça avec
vraiment les petits bras qui gigote la
boîte secrète c'est une boîte tirelire
tu dois mettre la thune dedans si j'ai
pas si j'ai bien compris
une fois que vous aurez déposé votre
pièce pourrait vous découvrir les
mystères du coffre fort pour la
récupérer nous allons mettre la pièce
inside carrière ah bon ça prêt à servir
de vraies tirelire pour les gens et
maintenant il faut trouver comment
ouvert la boîte pour récupérer la pièce
ça va pas du tout est relou pourquoi
j'ai mis la pièce de n'y a plus d'enjeu
on explore la banque et ça ça va ah oui
non ça se lève pas encore mais ça ça se
lèvera un lire ça bon c'est un bosseur
tourner d'accord ce davis ou pas j'aime
pas je commence à faire des actions sans
explorer c'est pas bien que non ça ne
dévisse pas on se retourne ça ça se lève
pas là y'a rien qui peut bouger
si si je le tourne
si je veux tant que peut pas y faire
grand chose
salah les pico je peux pas les âges peut
les tirer je peux être tirée je peux
tirer les pico loïc mais non tu reviens
je tirais les fico et et qu'est ce qu'il
ya c'est pas bien il peut tirer les
picot voilà [ __ ] un ont pourtant la
vidéo du coup non oui du coup merci
après revendre on attend j'essaie de lui
je les tire et louis aussi ok là je
tirais les pico est ce que du coup ça
bouge mieux
ok les pico devait bloquer quelque chose
ici là maintenant je peux lever cette
partie je peux l'enlever
ah non on peut juste là le hockey
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que j'ai en fait ça
qu'est-ce que j'en fais ça me permet
d'avancer plus nous avancent plus de là
est-ce que je peux relever quelque chose
de non lui peut-être non à hay et
première difficulté intéressant donc on
a trouvé les premières étapes il fallait
tourner ça il fallait tirer les pico il
fallait lever ce côté et poussez donc on
en a on a trouvé quatre étapes
là je me suis peut-être si c'est ça on
pouvait faire ça mais peut-être c'est
pas encore la bonne étape doit aussi
remarqué je peux pas le recul et je peux
que l'avancé ce pas ça doit pas être un
hasard conférence est ah oui non même sa
s'imbriquent très bien peut-être ici oui
nous avançons très vite faire le plus
difficile mais charlie une fois que je
suis là parce que du coup je peux au bon
nombre de jeux finis en même temps on
commence à avoir l'habitude des boîtes 1
mais on récupère l'enjeu bon en fait à
lui coule à les couleurs abbas matière
n'était pas dur à faire c'est quand même
plus dur que la pipe
on est vraiment sur trois étapes par
contre les styles et elle est très jolie
la déco est bien faite la fabrication
est bien fait et ça fait une vraie
tirelire sympa avec une petite ouverture
secrète
ok les boîtes japonaise c'est vachement
plus stylé tu vois mais les boîtes
japonais ça coûte aussi une fortune
alors que ça je crois que ça m'a coûté
15 balles un truc comme ça c'est pas
très cher tu vois avec la petite pièce
madeco la fab est belle non j'aime
j'aime bien bon on passe à lui qui
le plus dur par maison donc l'idée
l'idée de la maison c'est si j'ai bien
compris où tu dois mettre la pièce
ici il ya un labyrinthe caché à
l'intérieur et tu dois à la faire
ressortir par là ça c'est cool
ici il ya un petit livret avec des
indices alors là c'est à ça c'est en
anglais pour tout en angles de la chasse
est ouverte
placez la pièce sur le la devanture du
221b baker street et voyez si vous
pouvez naviguer
si vous pouvez trouver votre chemin ah
oui si vous pouvez trouver votre chemin
pour sortir la fenêtre qui à l'arrière
toi tu rentres dans l'entrée et que tu
va tout droit
tu as le hall et si tu prends tout de
suite à gauche et tu descends les
escaliers enfin et explique comment sont
toutes les pièces en fait il ya trois
niveaux il ya trois niveaux étaient
divisés en trois en trois parties comme
ça à l'intérieur
hyper intéressant on à la description
des trois partis en entier et de là il
faut comprendre quels chemins utilisés
mémoriser pour pouvoir passer de la
halle à santon b dans un endroit où on
pourrait plus bouger ok le je vais me
lire tout ça comme ça en anglais il faut
à la fois traduire dans sa tête à la
fois mémoriser et du coup pour ça je
réclame une petite accélération
[Musique]
ok ok donc là je vais aller dans la
cuisine ce qui devrait me faire passer à
l'étagé
du coup ça fait tak tak et voilà là j'ai
entendu un vrai bruit deux clowns donc
je t'attends d'un an tandis à loïc
[ __ ] [ __ ] je l'entends pas là je
n'entends pas je m'en fous non mais
j'entends palais la vidéo reprend la
vidéo est elle toujours suit mais ça ça
veut dire qu'on est descendu d'un cran
ok du coup là si j'ai bien compris il ya
ce chemin là mais moi il faudrait que je
prenne à gauche en bas à droite et que
je remonte pour atteindre donc là qu'il
ya ce qu'ils appellent l'escalier il
faut pas que j'aille au bout
hop donc là je suis pas allé au bout
j'ai tourné là et pour moi c'est à peu
près comme ça donc et je descends je la
droite et je vais donc là je suis
derrière les derrière si j'ai bien
compris toute l'énigme
maintenant j'ai peut-être pas bien
compris toute la ligne qu'est ce que la
caisse que lâcher paumé à non à ok donc
et j'ai fait un petit move lâcher dans
le grand corridor notre maître et là on
est d'accord ok donc là je vais aller là
ok ok i'm a nazi je me choque je me fais
dans le temps si bas que ce qu'on pense
ok je sais pas j'ai pu la pièce loïc
quoi elle serait là depuis le départ
quoi mais qu'est ce qui se passait cette
pièce était le machin là c'était un joli
fail aussi ok je le tente dans l'autre
sens
[Musique]
ok
j'ai retrouvé mois on a les deux sens je
pense qu'on a validé ces trois casses
têtes
écoutez j'ai kiffé sage et qui fait qu'
une série sherlock holmes j'ai kiffé que
le travail soigné g qui fait
l'originalité de ce casse tête parce que
j'ai jamais eu de trucs comme ça que
l'amiante est visible sur trois étages
avec une histoire qui va te donner en
fait des choses à déduire pour
comprendre le chemin et s'est du coup je
remballe sa très soigneusement je vous
fait gagner sur instagram je vous mets
dans la description un lien si vous
voulez vous le vous les achetez
directement en ligne
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne si vous aimez les casse-tête du
peu de casse tête comme ça que c'est un
petit peu un hors série des casse tête
n'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo à les
commenter parce que ça fait plaisir
et puis moi je vous dis à très bientôt
au zénith de paris et le 20 novembre
2020 cette date est évidemment
maintenues et vous pouvez prendre le
placier déjà 30% des places qui sont
partis n'hésitez pas à les prendre
maintenant pour avoir les meilleures
places vous avez un lire dans la
description pour voir mon spectacle mon
troisième spectacle c'est la fin de ce
spectacle un disant trop spectacle la
grande dernière au zénith de paris je
compte sur vous et à très bientôt ciao